le mont valérien savez vous ce qu'il
représente
et bien c'est un haut lieu du souvenir
français ici à l'ouest de paris pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale dans la
clairière de cette ancienne forteresse
qui domine la capitale les allemands au
tuer tuer tuer la citadelle du mont
valérien qui était un de leur abattoir
est aujourd'hui un lieu de pèlerinage
pour ceux qui pleurent les victimes
ici fonctionner la machine kerrigan a
donné la mort on ne l'oublierai pas
vous ne l'oublierez pas les allemands
avaient fait du mont valérien un lieu
d'exécution 1009 résistant fusillé que
tous les présidents vont commémorer à
commencer par vincent auriol en 1947 le
président de la république a poussé son
pèlerinage jusqu'au mont valérien hauts
lieux de la résistance et derniers
sanctuaires du sacrifice français le
général de gaulle s'y rendre à lui tous
les ans depuis 1944 le général de gaulle
n'a jamais failli à ce pèlerinage à
travers lequel chaque année le premier
résistant de france s'est attaché à
rendre un pieu hommage aux résistants
fusillés et avec à tous ceux dont le
sacrifice a contribué à rendre à la
france sa liberté et sa place dans le
monde
et en 1960 il inaugure ce monument
l'inauguration du mémorial à la france
combattante dans la nuit du mont
valérien associés dans un même hommage
tous les combattants de la dernière
guerre ceux qui ont lutté sur l'uniforme
et les autres soldats de l'ombre tombés
sous les balles aux morts dans un camp
de déportation derrière le mémorial une
crypte creusé à même la butte des
fusillés attendait l'urne et les
cercueils un monument colossal un mur de
150 mètres de long dominée par la croix
de lorraine et une flamme du souvenir
chaque 18 juin en hommage à l'appel à la
résistance du général de gaulle tous les
présidents viennent s'y recueillir un
passage obligé de georges pompidou à
emmanuel macron le mont valérien est
donc dédié à ces résistants un lieu à la
fois de mémoire et de communication
politique où l'on célèbre la france
résistante
alfred pognon
ricardo rigueur
mario jean
pierre le bois